um I hate the Chinese government how
they treat their people do you think
that China is just trying to make our
youth soft just in case I'm just going
for for militarily if you have to attack
or whatever as long as the men are soft
you can take over or like a revolution
from yeah sure I think absolutely they
look at they look at this as a as a as a
essentially a a cold war on many
different fronts right so they're out
there hoovering up economic information
right they're Gathering oh they've been
doing that for decades very aggressively
and they're busy building up their
military and they're also understanding
the impact of technology and they've
been looking at this I mean it's the
same you know it's Russian
disinformation whatever it may be it's
the same thing the Chinese just have
more the regime has more resources yeah
I agree with you I I it drives me crazy
when people go well look at you you
aren't you xenophobic yeah you know no
I'm talking look at Chinese culture
history people amazing right it's an
incredible place the regime
sucks